one of the advantages of doing
1994 is you don't have to
live with every decision we made
in the earlier movies
we produced the first Transformers movie
with Michael Bay that was almost two
decades ago now we're here for the price
of the bees new director a new cast new
characters introduced as well how has
that Journey been for you
it was unexpected first of all you know
you when you set out to make a movie you
don't think okay 19 years ago we started
the development
so I don't think you could possibly
think that's what's going to happen but
what has been really exciting is
really the participation of the audience
with these movies I mean these are
audience movies and so to experience
their laughter and their joy and their
AWS and oh my God look at that that's
really fun and it keeps you energized as
a filmmaker now I know this is the
seventh film and I know you said earlier
it's a sequel but can we like be more
clear is it a sequel to bumblebee to
like the five movies it's a sequel to
bumblebee because sequentially
Bumblebee's 1987 and this is 1994 and
the first one was 2007.
so we really look at it as a pretty
continuous timeline and one of the
advantages of doing
1994 is you don't have to
live with every decision we made
in the earlier movies
that makes these
moves so special it's an interesting
question because it's like why is the
audience love it so much I think the
answer is the same which is
many of us put a personality on our car
and to turn out that it has a
personality is really interesting and I
think there's just something
fundamentally joyful about that but I
also think it really is a kind of thing
where your imagination is allowed to go
in areas where it's just it's the only
kind of thing you could possibly all
right then let's do let's go to Machu
Picchu and you know and guess what
they've been there for thousands of
years you know so that's really fun now
I want to talk about that ending about
Noah at the end of you a completely
excited me also shocked me you mentioned
earlier that Stephen came in with this
idea like this direction in mind having
that conversation with him go
is
heat very early on brought up GI Joe and
and
um
my reaction was listen we've thought
about it a lot uh I'm very open what do
you how do you think it works and he
wasn't sure at that time so what
happened was as we were developing
taking the script and making it
including his world point of view his
emotional you know how he looked at the
Beast for instance because he grew up
with them he had a very specific thing
so what happened was
we kept coming back to G.I Jones on like
why
why would they know
first of all because part of what we've
tried to do in every Transformers is no
one's supposed to know they were here
other than in the fourth or fifth one
where they do know
so we went back to that where nobody's
supposed to know this has happened so
why would any organization know and
actually what was cool about we
certainly went well because they're GI
Joe they would know you know what I mean
which is an entirely uh logical but it's
emotionally logical that this top secret
thing would somehow know now this is my
last question and I'm sure this is the
question that everyone's going to ask
once they see the movie
what's next for these franchises we
don't know that's what's fun as we can
imagine you know I imagine GI Joe will
play a big part do we know no
I imagine that several of the beasts
will come along with us you know the
hardest part I think in a way is because
there's such a abundance of riches
if you put too much in then you the
audience doesn't know where to invest so
we have to keep the number of characters
to a certain number or else even in this
you know we spend a lot of time with
Optimus primal and air razor and not so
much with chidora and rhinox because you
just don't have the room for it so for
creatively what's so exciting is we have
some ideas for sure but which ones will
win we don't know